وفي كثير من اللاعبين الذين يعني ايييي
يعني كانوا يلعبوا لمنتخباتم وحينما يعني
كانوا اصولهم ليست من اصول لهذه المنتخبات
يعني جرى تجنيسهم حينما كان يعرض النشيد
كان يعبرون عن نوع من الاستياء لانهم يعني
في هناك حنين يشدهم الى بلادهم الاولى
التي يعني هجروا منها او ترد منها او لم
يجدوا فيها مثلا المكان الملائم اذا كره
القدم هي تعبير كبير عن كل هذه الصراعات
سواء كانت الصراعات فرديه او صراعات
جماعيه او اثنيه وبالتالي يعني وجدنا مثلا
في حينما فازت ال- ال- الارجنتين يعني همم
بكاس العالم كيف تم استثمار هذا الامر
حينما فازت ايطاليا بكاس العالم واهدت هذا
الفوز الى الفلسطينيين في لبنان عام 1982
كان له استثمار ودو كبير جدا في الاوساط
العالميه وبالتالي استثمار هذه الرياضه
يعني لاشياء نبيله تكون عالقه بالبال الذي
يعني يؤرقني انا كمحب لكره القدم ان تنزلق
هذه اللعبه بحيث لا تعود مصدرا للمتعه
وانما مصدرا لي نشر الكراهيه والحساسيه
بين الشعوب وهذا امر يعني يخرج اللعبه عن
سياقها يفقد الناس يعني هذه المتعه
النادره التي يعني توفرها هذه اللعبه يعني
الساحره التي تغذي يعني مفاهيم الايجابيه
في الانتصار في الصبر في التحدي في هزيمه
المستحيل
فهذه كلها يعني عناصر ايجابيه يمكن ان
نستثمر فيها طيب